la carte habt ihr vielleicht noch ein
bisschen verfolgt eine ziemlich würzige
mischung bisschen porno ziemlich viel
bilanzskandal uns eine prise lobbyismus
was man ihr das was er unter anderem
lobbyismus machen alte kontakte anzapfen
ist das anrüchig ist es illegal oder ist
völlig okay ich bin daniel pontzen vom
zdf hauptstadtstudio und ich finde das
ist ein thema bei dem man denselben
maßstab anlegen kann wie er früher bei
sein ich war von anfang an der meinung
dass wir hier sehr klare worte wählen
müssten und dass man gleichzeitig auch
die dinge erklärt und wenn man dinge
erklärt kommt es auch gelegentlich mal
darauf an klartext zu reden genau das
machen wir jetzt mal versuchen
guttenberg und wirecard doktorarbeit und
bilanzfälschung viele sagen passt
ziemlich gut zusammen noch mal kurz zur
erinnerung erst bestimmt mitbekommen
wirecard krasse erfolgsgeschichte mit
weniger als 5.000 beschäftigten sind die
größer geworden als die deutsche bank
mit knapp 100.000 mitarbeitern weil man
sich knallhart gerade zu beginn auf
wachstumsbranchen konzentriert hat porno
und glücksspielindustrie why not war er
legal zweifel gab es dann allerdings
recht bald an der bilanz zu fünf zentren
und dann zu 18 grad auch die süddeutsche
darüber berichtet darüber dass die
staatsanwaltschaft münchen verfahren
prüft und dass man auch im kanzleramt
angekommen wo kurz darauf auch eine
gesprächs anfrage eingehen wir haben
interne unterlagen aus dem ganzen am
vorliegen der wirecard chef markus braun
hatte damals um ein gespräch mit
kanzlerin angela merkel gebeten was der
welt schaffen wollte in den gesprächen
wissen wenn nicht ist aber eigentlich
auch egal denn ärzte nicht bekommen wenn
interne unterlagen aus dem kanzleramt
belegen die abgeordnetenwatch bekommen
hat dass man das geprüft hat intern und
dann gesagt hat besser finger weg ein
solches gespräch mit der kanzlerin sei
zitat vor dem hintergrund des sz bericht
über ein mögliches verfahren der
münchner staatsanwaltschaft nicht ratsam
ziemlich eindeutig eigentlich dann gegen
ein bisschen zeit ins land bis es
nochmal jemand probiert hat für wirecard
ein alter bekannter
wenn jemand der gerne redet
und ich glaube dass die kraft des wortes
manchmal allzu gering geschätzt wird
reden hilft und er guttenberg hat dann
termin gekriegt bei der kanzlerin in
seiner zweitkarriere als lobbyist was
vielleicht auch ein bisschen an seiner
erst karriere lag die älteren erinnern
sich vor gut zehn jahren war er der
senkrechtstart auf der berliner politik
bühne mit 37 der jüngste
wirtschaftsminister wir knapp 38
verteidigungsminister 39
zurückgetretenen minister
ich habe in einem sehr
freundschaftlichen gespräch die frau
bundeskanzlerin informiert dass ich mich
von meinen politischen ämtern
zurückziehen werde
freundschaftliches gespräch und seine
gründe ich fasse das mal zusammen seine
fehlerhafte doktorarbeit aber auch dass
zu viel aufmerksamkeit auf ihn gerichtet
worden seid ja vorher hatte sich darüber
selten beklagt in dem fall aber was
einfach zu viel
ich war immer bereit zu kämpfen aber ich
habe die grenzen meiner kräfte erreicht
ja etwas nüchterner klang das urteil der
zuständige untersuchungskommission die
befand dass herr freiherr zu guttenberg
die standards guter wissenschaftlicher
praxis evident grob verletzt und hierbei
vorsätzlich getäuscht hat
nur außen die kanzlerin allerdings die
war ja auch nicht allzu strengen mit
herrn guttenberg die hatte vorher schon
gesagt sie hatte ihn als
verteidigungsminister eingestellt ich
habe keinen wissenschaftlichen
assistenten oder einen promovierenden
oder einen inhaber einer doktorarbeit
berufen
noch immer war dann erstmal raus gab ein
buch vorerst gescheitert betonung auf
vorerst denn das buch enthielt vor allem
auch einen ausblick auf das zitat was
eines der größten politischen talente
gegenwärtig und in zukunft bewegt bewegt
hat er sich dann erst mal richtung usa
und da hat eine firma gegründet
spitzberg partner ist eine firma die
unter anderem lobbyarbeit macht das
heißt da hat dann seine zweitkarriere
als lobbyist begonnen und auch da hat er
sich nicht mit mittelmaß zufrieden
gegeben
eigentlich kaum zu fassen
ein ehemaliger bundesminister nutzt
seine exzellenten kontakte in die
politik und nimmt als top lobbyist für
etliche zwielichtige unternehmen
einfluss zum beispiel neben wirecard
nochmal zusammengefasst erstens
guttenberg verliert seinen posten als
minister zweitens er geht in die usa an
startet eine karriere als lobbyist und
drittens das schafft er dann das was der
wald chef wo er nicht geschafft hat mit
merkel über wirecard zu sprechen
zu dem gespräch kam es im september 219
wohnung ging es da in diesem gespräch
hintergrund war merkel hat damals eine
reise nach china geplant und wirecard
wollte damals auf dem chinesischen markt
fuß fassen wollte nicht chinesische
firma übernehmen
und da schrieb guttenberg in der mail an
den zuständigen abteilungsleiter im
kanzleramt waren wir uns einig dass ein
kurzer hinweis im rahmen des besuches
sehr hilfreich sein könnte vermutlich
und weiter die frau bundeskanzlerin bat
mich ihnen noch einige zeilen zukommen
zu lassen um die richtige formulierung
an der hand zu haben ja ihr seid dann
gern nachgekommen die formulierungshilfe
gab es im anhang und daneben die reise
nach china und ist merkel dann
tatsächlich dem wunsch nachgekommen das
thema work hard anzusprechen was meint
ihr thema ist durch die chefin
angesprochen worden schreibt der
abteilungsleiter hinterher dann in der
mail an guttenberg zusatz ich werde das
auch weiter flankieren weiter für einen
klaren ja das jetzt genau die grauzone
in die lobbyismus immer wieder vorstöße
persönliche kontakte nutzen um sich
kleine gefälligkeiten zu erbitten wenn
manchmal gar nicht so kleiner wirkung
auch nicht für guttenberg bzw das konto
seiner firma etwas mehr als 900 70.000
euro sollen von wirecard an seine firma
spitzberg geflossen sein
wie die frankfurter allgemeine
sonntagszeitung aus dem umfeld von
wirecard erfahren hat schreibt sie und
dann ist er auch noch von prämien die
rede sind es je schneller man in china
zum ziel kommt umso höher der bonus für
guttenberg
ziemlich lukratives geschäftsmodell
würde ich sagen und die rolle der
kanzlerin einmal im jahr gibt es bei uns
in berlin für die hauptstadtjournalisten
eine große sommer pk mit ihr da kann man
sie alles fragen und darum wird sie
dieses jahr eben auch zum thema wirecard
befragt und sie meinte dass es passieren
kann dass man zu einem zeitpunkt geboren
von solchen unregelmäßigkeiten keine
kenntnis hat man sich für ein
unternehmen auch einsetzt
das halte ich auch für gegeben keine
kenntnis das ist unwahrscheinlich wir
hatten ja interne unterlagen vorliegen
und genau darum ging es letztendlich als
man merkel davon abriet sich mit
wirecard chef markus braun zu treffen
eben aufgrund der
medienberichterstattung also das ist für
viele jetzt lobbyismus champions league
eine dubiose firma schafft ist mit einem
über seine doktorarbeit gestolpert ein
ex minister auf die agenda der kanzlerin
was meint ihr wenn man solche fälle von
lobbyist musik brauchen wir das oder
muss das weg genau das habe ich diese
ziemlich krassesten kritiker von
lobbyismus gefragt lobbycontrol ein
gemeinnütziger verein der wie der name
schon sagt lobby kontrollieren will
und die sagen lobbyismus ist prinzipiell
ok lobbyismus im sinne von
interessensvertretung ist sogar
notwendig für eine demokratie ist
wichtig dass politikerinnen und
politiker im ständigen austausch sind
mit gesellschaftlichen gruppen das ist
wichtig für die demokratie
das problem es gibt da so eine art
wettbewerbsverzerrung weil die verbände
und konzerne die viel geld haben sich
eben auch die besser verdrahtet ein
lobbyist den lobbyisten leisten können
und das sind eben oft solche die vorher
topjobs in der politik hatten dabei
haben sie sehr viel wissen erworben also
insider wissen sie haben ein prall
gefülltes adressbuch sie wissen wie der
hase läuft in der politik und diese
spezielle wissen ist natürlich wertvoll
für lobbyisten und lobbyisten aber der
anstand sollte doch so sein dass
politikerinnen und politiker diese
spezielle wissen nicht einfach an die
privatwirtschaft weitergeben sollte ja
wenn der anstand nicht ganz so
ausgeprägt ist dann soll die sogenannte
karenzzeit helfen
kühl phase zwischen der zeit als
politiker und derzeit als lobbyist eine
phase in der man nicht direkt all diese
kontakte und das wissen zu geld macht
diese abkühlphase die dauert in
deutschland zwölf monate maximal 18
monate manche experten wünschen sich
drei jahre aber wenn sie jemand gut
kennen dann kennen sie ihn auch noch
nach drei jahren und weil gute kontakte
bleiben gute kontakte das ist ganz klar
das kennt man aus dem alltäglichen leben
man vergisst einfach die kontakte und
die leute nicht ja und dieses alte
kontakte anzapfen das gibt es
parteiübergreifend helmut kohl für kirch
gerd schröder für gazprom joschka
fischer berät unter anderem siemens und
bmw
daniel bahr von der fdp der wechselte zu
allianz und und und jüngstes besonders
eindrückliches beispiel er hier sigmar
gabriel früher wirtschaftsminister und
in der funktion bei unter anderem auch
mal bei tönnies fleisch hat sich damals
wahnsinnig über die werks vertragspraxis
geärgert eine schande für deutschland
sei das abgeschafft hatte das damals
dann aber nicht hat eine
selbstverpflichtung für die industrie
eingeführt die wie wir heute wissen ja
nicht so wahnsinnig viel geändert hat
nach seiner politkarriere hat ihm das
dann allerdings nicht mehr ganz so
angewidert da dann nämlich einen
beratervertrag von tunis bekommen und
10.000 euro im monat 10.000 euro oder
wie gabriel meinte ein total übliches
honorar der branche ich kann nichts
verwerfliches daran erkennen ein
unternehmen bei export problemen mit
china zu beraten kann er nicht erkennen
gabriel so ein typisches beispiel für
einen spitzenpolitiker der noch während
seiner amtszeit solche seitenwechsel
kritisiert hat dann aber auch dankbar
lobby angebote angenommen hat als er
nicht mehr in der politik war das ist
natürlich so ein bisschen heuchlerisch
wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt was ist das
für ein business dieser lobbyismus muss
man fairerweise sagen das ist nur ein
ausschnitt
ich hätte interessiert wie sieht es denn
in der praxis außen da habe ich mal
angefragt dem lobbyismus arbeitet sich
an alle anstandsregeln hält und hat mit
dem alle vorurteile abgeklopft viertes
in 60 sekunden klischee 1 kontakte sind
in ihrem job alles die kontakte sind
vieles man kommt sonst kann ich jetzt
gespräche aber die argumente sind immer
noch wichtig insofern kontakte sind
wichtig aber nicht alles
das einfluss leben passiert bei gutem
rotwein den hinterzimmern herren e das
einfluss nehmen passiert wenn man glück
hat bei gutem kaffee hat bei schlechten
kaffee und dann meistens am heimischen
schreibtisch oder im büro der
abgeordneten
die drei sie formulieren textbausteine
für gesetzesentwürfe vor und schicken
die dann per mail an die abgeordneten
ja das machen wir manchmal meistens sind
wir aber ein konsultationsverfahren
unterwegs das heißt wir schicken das
dann im normalen verfahren wie alle
anderen auch per e mail sowie ist muss
hat so einen schlechten ruf weil viele
politiker die seiten wechseln am ende
ihrer karriere um geld abzugreifen
lobbyismus hat einen schlechten ruf weil
vieles intransparent ist aber so viele
politikerinnen und politiker sind ja gar
nicht unterwegs ja aber sie prägen
natürlich sehr stark das bild
interessant ist allerdings dass
ausgerechnet wirecard und guttenberg
jetzt so eine verbesserung von
lobbyismus beitragen könnten indirekt
zumindest
gibt es jetzt ein untersuchungsausschuss
unter anderem eben auch zu der frage
inwieweit politik da eingespannt war
merkel steht plötzlich wie eine
regierungschefin da die sich von
lobbyisten einspannen lässt und
womöglich war es auch so und guttenberg
was hat er zu befürchten hat er
überhaupt was zu befürchten er hat
vermutlich gar nichts zu befürchten denn
er hat gegen keine regelungen verstoßen
die es geben würde das das ding es gibt
nämlich in deutschland überhaupt kein
regelwerk für lobbyismus
das soll sich nun ändern es soll ein
sogenanntes lobbyregister geben ähnlich
wie es das schon gibt in den usa zum
beispiel oder in brüssel
da ist das große ziel den leuten den
bürgerinnen und bürgern zu sagen wer für
was einfluss ausgeübt hat mit welchen
mitteln wie viel geld da geflossen ist
wie viel personen dahinter stehen und
mit wien die person da gesprochen hat
das ziel also transparenz schaffen die
frage ist allerdings wird der entwurf
der dazu ausgearbeitet worden ist und
jetzt vorliegt wird der dieses ziel am
ende erreichen oder wird es am ende nur
so eine art feigenblatt wir sind sehr
froh das ist so ein lobbyregister
überhaupt geben wird denn es ist ja
davon auszugehen
aber es ist durchaus noch ein bisschen
luft nach oben also es ist auf jeden
fall wichtig dass die bundesregierung
dabei ist dass es nicht nur ein
lobbyregister für das parlament ist weil
viele gesetze in der bundesregierung
auch gemacht werden und nicht erst im
bundestag
es ist auch wichtig dass die finanzen
nochmals klarer gefasst werden also mit
wie viel geld wird einfluss genommen
also fazit lobbyismus ist okay sogar
notwendig in einer demokratie es muss
möglich sein dass jeder seine meinung
jeder seine expertise einbringen kann in
den gesetzgebungsprozess das wichtigste
ist dass das transparent geschieht
bislang gibt es da eben kaum regeln in
deutschland jetzt soll ein sogenanntes
lobbyregister kommen ob das der große
game changer wird zu hören wir sehen da
müssen wir sehr auf die details achten
tja und wirecard die beiden davon
wahrscheinlich nur noch sehr betroffen
seien für die geht ja vorher das
gescheitert
für ihn haben nochmal aber wir können
diskutieren was sagt ihr zum thema
lobbyismus schreibt eure meinung in die
kommentare
und ganz wichtig dabei dass man nicht um
den heißen brei herumredet ganz genau
und damit möglichst viele diskutieren
teilt das video gerne und vor allem
abonniert uns dafür und fürs zuschauen
schon mal vorab vielen dank